Jiro and you should know such things, of course you
know.It was one-half.If you ask me what kind of person it is,I'm one of the three legendary disciples of the Third Hokage.The legendary Sannin Hooker and the two are ahhh!  The
4th generation, the 7th generation, and two generations of casualties,
not only my father, but also my grandfather,
who played a leading role in the civil assembly
war, who brought peace to the current Konoha.
Was he such a fine person?
Certainly, Jiraiya-sama had a great day
.  I heard that
I stepped down from the position of Hokage voluntarily
, Noah,
and when I became Hokage, I was fighting over the
Hokage.
I did
n't even know it was a true story Ah,
when I was your age, I was gathering all of Sato
's expectations.
I'm wondering if you know about tactics
.
ok
it's too early for you guys